[Music]
all right have you guys
seen this guy before i like him like
he's like this like the soap opera
that's so problematic
uncle roger uncle roger yeah it reminds
me of uh
uncle sam and uncle chen actually really
does yeah
because he does the accent well his
accents are actually semi
authentic too because he's from malaysia
he has a malaysian accent but he does
put it on a little he puts on a little
bit like a
like a chinese who is this guy he's a
comedian from malaysia but now i think
he's living in london
so he's like he's i don't know he went
viral
like super viral we should bring him on
we should
i'm a fan of this guy but yeah his name
is nigel ing
and uh he recently went viral for
calling out different chefs for making
fried rice
the wrong way fried rice [ __ ] fried
rice the first video i saw was him
telling people like uh how they washed
the rice prawn
oh yeah i seen that one yes this is the
first one he went viral for
oh yes i've seen it what she doing
what's he doing drain the oh my god
you're killing me woman hi a drinker
she devised she's draining rice with
coal and the high
colander you just do it in the pot and
then you go
yeah she said why is that wrong
i mean yeah why so i guess i don't i
don't know it's not the asian way
it's not the way that's actually smarter
though yeah that's why i'm like why is
it wrong because if you have it here
right and the water is going right here
you go like this and literally all the
bad guys are just
yeah we're going to do it multiple times
then should we take
raw rice grains like dry rice grains and
then
wash it in a colander then that would be
the smarter way in this video she cooked
she cooked it and then drained it okay
no that's weird
that's weird that is weird no you get
rice you use
you wash it put it in the pot soak it in
water
for about a couple hours and then you
cook it wait so
when she cooked the rice was the rice
dry and then she added water to wash it
or like i don't get it so she okay first
of all so
with the rice in particular she did many
things wrong
from a asian perspective uh she
first put dry rice into a saucepan
no rice cooker all right sauce pan and
then she let she measured
one cup of rice no she measured two cups
of water for every cup of rice
oh that's not enough anything about
cooking rice the asian way
that's [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] time it's 101.
it's this
yes the pinky oh right
and so that's first mistake second
mistake was
after she was done cooking it it was
super
watery so then she had to drain it first
she drained it in a colander and after
that she washed it
with cold water and cold water yeah
maybe she's just that
that she's from another country and
that's just how they do it i don't know
any asians that do it
even though we have different rice like
long grain short grain
and we wash rice a little bit
differently or whatever but
washing rice after you cook it that's
weird i don't know
anyone that does that me neither why
would you do that it almost feels like
it would ruin the texture of the rice
like i but then i don't just bomb
afterwards though she's like super
interesting it looks amazing afterwards
and let me see if i can pull it i mean
i've seen noodles be cooked that way
when you eat like cold noodles or
whatever you cook the noodles and then
you
you rinse it out well that's to stop the
cooking right so that it doesn't
get softer kind of flashes the the
texture
as it is yeah so he first roasted this
chick
for making rice the wrong way and then
since then
they've actually teamed up and made
another cookie oh cool
she's real cool about it like she
understood it was just standing for last
or whatever
so they're real chill but now he's
nigel ing is going after some bigger
fish and recently he released a video
going after uh jamie oliver and if you
know jamie oliver he's a
pretty famous chef tv personality he
started making fried rice
and he had some things to say about his
fried rice
no no no no no no no
putting jam in rice
this is disgusting who put gems
what is it what was the strawberry jam
it was chili jam what's chili jam
i don't know i've never heard of a chili
jam what dish were they making
fried rice what even even if it wasn't
jam even if it was like
chili oil or chili i mean you just don't
necessarily put it
during the cooking process no you put at
the end yeah
a lot of like different kinds of fried
rice there is i feel like there's no
like fried rice one way because you
but it's typically you get
day old rice yeah yes yes you don't
[ __ ] use fresh rice jamie oliver was
using packet rice
just to make things worse i mean that
was a whole nother bit that
uh nigel lane's subjective though very
subjective you know to be fair in the
modern world
like we don't even know what that jam is
but if it was bomb
i don't know if i could yeah i don't
know if i could scrutinize it i just
don't know what it is
he's a purist though there's a way to do
chinese fried rice and he just wants to
make sure
that's not is it was it specifically
chinese fried rice uh it's egg fried
rice specifically you can see that's
friday right egg is a very international
concept here true
true how do you guys make your egg fried
rice i
use day old rice mm-hmm dale rice i
throw that [ __ ] in there sounds
about right
no first i prime it with uh sesame oil
you know prime that [ __ ] with
sesame oil i got my
ingredients right all of the vegetables
chopped up into the little pieces
maybe some balagna you know maybe some
kind of leftovers that i want to just ch
some kind of something you know ham or
spam or whatever sam is like a leftover
thing because that's
that's what i heard about fried rice is
like you're supposed to just put
leftover food yeah it's like the spam of
your kitchen just like whatever's left
that's true you could throw it in and
then you [ __ ]
and then you throw in the rice but then
you crack an egg and then you put the
egg inside because it also soaks up the
[ __ ] dry rice
that's a day old and then
you get the soy sauce and then if you're
vietnamese you do the uh nah i'm not
that skilled
if you're vietnamese you do the uh uh
fish sauce
mom but then game changer right japanese
we add butter i usually have the food
butter furikake or the uh it's like a
red pepper
it's it's called suga it's like you put
that on and you go
and you say rice is served oh is that
what you made remember that one time i
came over i think you made fried rice
that was pretty good
i don't remember but thank you he makes
it with kimchi
that's kimchi fried rice kimchi fried
rice i'll make some country fries right
i love kimchi fried rice but yeah so
when it comes to fried rice are there
to your knowledge are there any like
specific
blasphemous things just like yeah just
you just don't do it any other way but
this way i don't think so because for me
even when i make fried rice
every single time it's different because
i'm using different ingredients
yeah so like let's say if i if i like
let's say made barbecue the other day
and i have some leftover brisket or
something i really like the smokiness of
the brisket
so the brisket will be the first thing i
actually throw in the pan
and i kind of render the fat off of
there because i know it's going to
create a smokiness
my day old rice because everything is
going to be leftovers my daily rice i
actually put that in the microwave first
so that's already half cooked so i don't
use the pan to cook the rice the rice
now is immediately
going to go in there soak up the smoke
smoke fat so it's like each approach is
different sometimes i do the rice first
sometimes i throw the meat first
sometimes i'm like oh this veggie looks
undercooked
i cook the veggie first you know they're
all like different but
washing the rice after you cook it
that's [ __ ] that's wrong that kind of
makes me think
like that's like making fried rice
and then washing it
you make like too much flavor in here
you just rinse off the [ __ ] flavor
real quick
that's true literally done that with
some of bart's cooking before
you oh five spice the five spice meat oh
that's another one no i try to make uh
like brazilian barbecue one time the
pecania
and i put too much salt on it i remember
that i was trying to rinse that
[ __ ]
you know what though i would have to say
that bart is really good at
cooking textures like it's like the the
like the rib and all that and all those
have came out pretty well
the only time he's [ __ ] up would
probably be like that big ass brisket
where oh that was bad i mean that shit's
gonna take hours and it's hard it's it's
not easy to do it's enough patience yeah
like like the whole over-salting [ __ ] is
[ __ ] real
it's been a repetitive uh repeat
offender so
like the meat and then under the sink
you were like and it was still
salty yeah so he finished cooking the
dish dinner is served
and then i go to bite it and immediately
all my saliva just [ __ ] dries
and i was like holy [ __ ] so we started
just dunking his meat in our all of our
water glasses because it was just
it was unbearable i think like my my
tongue it's like you know you know when
you try to drink coke after you eat
chocolate
and the coke doesn't even taste sweet
anymore i think my tongue is like that
where as
i'm taste testing as i'm cooking the
salt receptors
is getting like over stimulated so i'm
like oh it's not even salty anymore what
the hell
really so now i just salt it once and
then i don't taste it at all until
way at the end and then i taste it again
and i get a second opinion
and i'm like oh thank god but you are
making things that you can't
test in between like they're oven made
or like whatever they're wrapping it
yeah so you have to do it once and then
figure it out like once you finish
that's where it's kind of dangerous yeah
but the stuff in between now like the
ones that i can like fried rice i try to
like
test it yeah killing it yeah that's
funny
i love cooking though man cooking's so
fun i love making leftovers like you
know what you have like at the end of
the week and you got oh i got a little
bit of bok choy here a little bit of
whatever i'm like what can i do with it
i like that soup thing that you make
that tycho really likes
oh the name that i can't say on camera
yeah there's a name we can't say
anything
he ignore him he's just being dumb
really yeah
really
[Laughter]
really he's just being stupid he's just
[ __ ] with you guys
it doesn't have a name i think it's just
called techsoup no we got a name you
[ __ ] i'm gonna choke your
[ __ ] ass out
i don't know what the name of this is
just mixing
a bunch of ingredients like slops in a
pot
sometimes that should taste so good it
does taste good just like
vegetables and meat in a [ __ ] pot and
you eat it like
a soup porridge kind of thing it looks
like garbage and you don't even know why
but it tastes good i'm such a woman i'm
such a little [ __ ] when i see that i'm
like oh man that doesn't look edible i'm
alright
what yeah dude really i really feel like
i could take anything throw it into a
soup
salted up sriracha especially when you
spice something
when you like hide the taste the flavor
with something spicy
one of my for you guys one of my
favorite fried rices was uh
i had bok choy with um like soul filet
made that i
simmered in like chicken broth but then
i had the bok choy leftovers has garlic
and chicken broth in the bok choy then i
made like
uh like broccolini with tomatoes or
something for some other italian dish
that i made
you fancy dude so yeah at the end of the
week when i had like all these things
they're all like pre-marinated stuff
and the it was [ __ ] bomb because it
had like [ __ ] flavors that took like
a week to make
but yeah so apparently the only thing
that uncle roger
actually agreed with with these with
these chefs was the fact that they
made a hole in the middle and cracked
the egg you know how you're supposed to
make a hole with the rice that seems to
be the universal knowledge of that
portion of the uh recipes that works
yeah yes
yeah because if you just smear it on it
makes the rice
super soggy like you gotta cook it a
little bit and then you mix it up
yeah oh so you make the hole in the pan
yeah yeah you make a hole so the egg
gets a little cooked
and it's and it's hard it's like a
bullet french toast is that what it's
called
i've never heard of that where you uh
for example take the piece of bread and
then you take like a cup
and then you cut the a hole of the bread
and then you put the egg in there
so then you cook it like that and then
you flip it over so the egg is within
the bread
that's crazy yeah it's really good they
do want to be from vendetta i think
what's the name of the soup
oh sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you